oh what a Oh
that ended quick that ended quickly I
thank you
where are the lovers Oh over there well
I'm so glad you're in a good mood a lot
of people it's country aren't but you
must be feeling the way I feel nostalgic
because of Ebola for one something went
viral and it's actually viral that's the
good news about Ebola the bad news of
course is that it has made the sexy
nurse costume for Halloween
typically obsolete so what I was gonna
wear this year now I'm gonna make jokes
about this of course I have to it's my
job but I have to tell you I am really
pissed about this how badly this was
handled one patient came here we could
have quashed it right away have you read
about what was going on in that hospital
down in Dallas thanks a lot Texas he was
left in the emergency room for three
hours with other patients there was
protective gear they gave the nurses
didn't cover their neck that was bodily
fluids literally piled up to the ceiling
at one point some [ __ ] actually hit a
fan what is that
leaving the neck exposed when you're
dealing with a boat state wearing a
condom that only covers your balls
Wow
well now we have Anna bolas or hopefully
he will be answering the tough questions
like I have a bola should I get on a
plane because up until now the answers
but yeah go ahead and joy happy travels
join the mile-high club take a cruise
you heard about this today yes somebody
who was working in the hospital now is
on a Carnival Cruise Line which leads to
two big questions will there be an
outbreak and how will they know
hey you've just handled a boa infected
fecal matter what are you gonna do go to
Disneyland not that they have any
credibility at this point anymore but
the State Department said the cruise
ship situation is under control because
they said the hospital worker who is on
the ship with her traveling companion
they've agreed to stay isolated in their
cabin I mean they're gonna go up to the
buffet table that's a given it's this
America we can't restrict our freedom
but other than that they're gonna stay
now this may be the first cruise where
people actually lose weight well it's
getting bad out there something my god
Taco Bell is not clapping their
breakfast burrito the good diarrhea
maker
now to try to calm things the president
met with the nurses who have taken care
of Ebola patients yesterday and he shook
hands with them he hugged them he kissed
them what no twerking come on if we're
gonna calm nerves let's put our ass into
it mr. president
wow you thought people were distancing
themselves from Obama before
well they are especially the Democrats I
mean his popularity is so low the Senate
Kentucky candidate the Democrat won't
say she voted for him Joe Biden was at
his high school reunion the other day
they asked him what he's been up to the
last six years he said you know
different stuff now politically you
heard about fan gate anybody from
Florida I love this right you know what
I'm talking about there was a debate
last night in the Florida Governor
toriel race between charlie Crist and
Brooks got the governor and Charlie
Christie was right here on this show a
few months ago he used a little fan he's
a sweater like remember Nixon lost the
presidency cos he okay so here's a
little fad well the other guy would not
come out until he got rid of the fan and
then he finally had to come out this is
what they're arguing about in politics
these days
today Bill Clinton came out defending
charlie Crist he said I always had fans
blowing me under the lectern what
oh oh you got dirty minds that's
certainly not what I meant by that and
the way you read those double entendre
into it it's ridiculous but of course
the other big story this week how bout
it Pope Francis has done it again he had
a big conference there at the Vatican
they released the port they said they
should be more welcoming to gay people
they should respect the dignity of gay
people this is coming from the Vatican
they should acknowledge the
contributions Wow
this is uh yeah this is this is all part
of Francis's plan to keep coming up with
surprises that could kill Pope Benedict
but apparently it's working I passed a a
church on my way into work today in West
Hollywood it's a it's called our Our
Lady of Gaga Wow
the sign out front said Wednesday bingo
Friday karaoke so I oh really
uh